with the holiday shopping season here
online retailers are hoping sales
continue to surge this year a National
Retail Federation estimates sixty-eight
point seven million Americans will shop
online this Cyber Monday and last year
Amazon the biggest online retailer sold
more than a hundred and eighty million
items over the five-day period from
Thanksgiving to Cyber Monday but what
you might not know is that the item you
just bought online could have been
sitting on your local store shelf
moments before you paid for it we went
out on the road to meet the people who
are shopping just to sell and what are
you hoping to find I'm hoping to find
some toys today toy Chris Anderson goes
to great lengths to land a deal logging
40,000 miles a year in his van Anderson
is an Amazon seller practicing retail
arbitrage here's how it works
a seller like Anderson buys an item for
a discounted price in one market like a
store and then sells it for a profit in
another market such as Amazon when
Anderson spots a promising deal he uses
a smartphone app to see just how much
and how often it's selling for online
then he scales up buying it again and
again it all goes into his van and then
to his 200,000 square foot warehouse in
central Pennsylvania once it sells it
goes to an amazon fulfillment center and
then on to the buyer its bargain hunting
on a big scale and anderson pockets the
profit all of this here is about $2,000
worth of soy sauce and i bought it from
a trader in philadelphia and you're
gonna sell it for probably five to ten
thousand dollars yeah that's a lot of
money it is but it's also a lot of work
how far have you gone to find your deals
oh I've driven all the way down to
Florida all the way up to Maine
Massachusetts I've gone all the way out
to Iowa pretty much anywhere I bet you
found some unusual things though
absolutely were the more unusual things
I found was a whole bunch of beer tap
handles I found it
200 of those in a store and they're like
40 50 bucks on eBay and Amazon and I was
buying them for $5.00 and sold them all
real fast people love them so it's the
unusual yeah it's the discontinued the
hard-to-find I'm gonna play a game with
you name that item back scratcher never
sold back scratchers fur coats don't do
fur raincoats
oh I've sold a lot of raincoats nose
clippers I sell a lot of personal care
items mousetraps
I've sold mousetraps good moneymaker not
really
some of these will see a 30 $40 profit
on other ones we'll see you 15 or 20 Wow
arbitrage is nothing new outlets like
Amazon eBay Craigslist Facebook
marketplace and Poshmark have
turbocharged the business this Brady
here I was picking these up for
literally like two three bucks and they
were calling for like 15 16 dollars all
day long that's led to an online
community of sellers who are getting in
on the action they are today including
my crazy Resendez yeah I think we might
have hit a little bit of a jackpot here
he's been selling products online for 15
years when I looked this up on Amazon
the rink is a hundred and nine thousand
and home improvement which isn't bad but
selling it for 43 25 FBA would only pay
out 33 18 and since we have to pay 35
plus tax to buy this that that is a
no-go now easy says he's done five
million dollars in sales on Amazon alone
often spending thousands of dollars on a
single shopping trip to flip all this
merchandise we have so much data
available to us as sellers it's not like
back in the day when you ran a store and
you ordered product you don't know
what's gonna sell well I know what's
selling I know how fast it's selling I
know what it's selling for on average
and so I know how much I can buy there's
no there's not a lot of guesswork
involved in it like
profit minimum to as much as 600 dollars
in profit in there right there 30
minutes later but raizy takes it a step
further his YouTube channel breezy
resells is dedicated to helping novice
sellers stay in the black top clearance
stuff is down low and up high let other
people in on how good you got so what
happened was for the longest time I
didn't tell anybody what I did and I was
super like I thought I was like James
Bond right I was super quiet about it I
always wanted to help people and change
the world and then I was like oh this is
how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna teach
people how to make money online and
they're gonna appreciate that and oddly
enough I actually make more money now
that I share information cuz oh it's
like the universe just keeps giving back
and that's what I'm a fan of kind of a
pay it forward mentality yeah definitely
and it's paying you back they actually
make more money now doing the YouTube
and the social media
then I do actually selling stuff I
didn't really start out helping people I
just started doing it and then what
happened was I would get messages from
people and they'd be like oh you helped
me oh we're in Disneyland with the kids
and it's all because of you you know
people would find me in public and
approach me crying like oh I paid off my
college loan debt because of you and I'm
like oh wow it's something we saw
firsthand on a recent shopping trip with
Reesie
I saw your videos I like how you're
giving people tips
as a site income but while folks like
resi make it look easy there are plenty
of risks involved if this is going to be
your actual way of making a living then
there are hard costs that are wired into
the process so it's not just the
warehouse and it's the time and it's
insurance and it's being able to
actually keep track of what you have
it's not for everybody and I think it's
probably not for most people but that
doesn't keep Chris Anderson from living
a life out on the road this has been the
best job I've ever had
so Anderson's shopping his way from
Pennsylvania to Minnesota during this
big shopping week and while he has that
big van he's part of that community of
sellers we told you about he's able to
send out shipments from the road with
their help and yes that means some of
the stuff that he is literally buying
right now is already on its way out it's
crazy it's the time thing what Jill said
at the end there that would be the one
thing it's such a great idea you want to
be able to do it but the time you have
to invest to find out it's a real job
but it's a fun job yeah it is I mean
Reesie says he banks something like 70
grand
whereas chris anderson said a hundred
but you know that's just on the retail
arbitrage what they do beyond that in
terms of sponsorships and YouTube
channel YouTube channels all of that
these things yeah I have chain they have
really here